it's time to live from the Jon Lovitz
aah gasping oh this Hollywood babble-on
with your hosts Kevin Smith
garden
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody how nice it is Saturday
night in Hollywood's let's babble the
[__] on I'm Kevin Smith I'm Rob Garvin
Wow oh man right across the face neck
and chest it has a lot of love from the
room couldn't get my name out I was a
gum no premature applause nation I'm say
girls episode on HBO do you watch that I
had a don't because I've never seen a
more unlikable group of people on
television more so than Sex and the City
women
oh yeah and like them Sex in the City
women I didn't I didn't have loved one
second hey man where's the other show
doing another show up there yeah PS shut
the [__] up
take it away sir um I didn't love the
Sex and the City girls no but at least I
wanted to [__] them for the most part
okay
but you're always attacking the one man
well the one who looks like a horse
wearing my Manolo Blahniks you turn her
over Manolo Blahnik No
Secretariat Jessica Parker move the [__]
on what's your point my point was this
past week on girls was a big story it
was a big hubbub a big hullabaloo about
one one scene in the TV show where
Sheree app will be remember her from
Roswell that show no okay she played the
girlfriend of some unlikable guy on the
show is if there's any other kind on
girls and he was having sex with her and
he pulled out and shot his load all over
her chest and so they cut to a shot of
her laying back there with his essence
all over her chest
[__] pearl necklace yeah yeah is that
a first for television I believe so
Envy this generation all right when I
was a young lad talking watching bowling
for dollars I dreamed about ginseng all
over the over the lane yeah and the
Polar's chest [__] like that so there
was a big deal everybody was in an
uproar about the fact that they showed
that on television I didn't hear that
yeah I thought of all people if there
was jism involved you would be
interested that's what I'm saying man
like I've got my [__] ear to the
[__] grindstone another mixed
metaphor is about when it comes to come
in the entertainment I know and that
didn't pop up on my come door
that's what I'm here for to fill you in
on a Jack youlet on television looking
to become I miss you catch that's right
and throw it back at me let me can I
tell you how dare you sir can I share
something real quick before I came in I
wish I brought the picture give to James
here at the Lovett's it's a bit of a
thing I can't just here's a picture like
and it goes up you have to send it three
days in advance in order for it to go up
on the screen and [__] so before I came
I was coming up I guess Orlando mega
cons going on right now Laura and some
dude was like I saw the grossest thing
in the world
Jay and Silent Bob making out and he had
a picture I finally released that
picture did that I guess there was a
picture no it wasn't hand
oh sorry there was a picture of a
Bluntman and chronic at Orlando Megacon
like in full
makeout mode thankfully there's another
picture it was a boy and girl
boyfriend/girlfriend and [__] yeah but
I'll be honest with the III for the
moment that I saw it blood rushed a
little bit did you let Muse in on that
let him know next show I'm on with him
they were boyfriend and girlfriend which
one was the girl the girl was chronics
Oh even cooler for me man yeah because
that's the J person in the relation I
was gonna say I wouldn't envy that guy
if the girl was blunt man with a beard
and everything you know do you want to
know it's like the [__] chick with a
beer just right here buddy alright
that's moving on take it between these
and brother face neck and chest
and we're back to that girls episode all
over there call [__] boys cuz my boys
would be swimming [__] all over your
face neck and check I'm sorry I you
brought up the car I know I'm sorry I
pursued this line of questioning Your
Honor I'd like to take a recess if you
don't mind let's start the show up as we
do each and every week where we like to
single out some folks who have come
particularly long distances or
celebrating special occasions it's a
segment we call the shout outs
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a bad omen you've dropped your [__]
I've never seen you drop the [__] before
it was so long I was stepping on it we
have new cords this week awesome why
people get here us totally yeah yeah
last week it was a bit of a hectic
episode but listen to this this is
fantastic alright again we get a ton of
these and if you sent one in and we
can't don't get a chance to read it we
apologize back throw someone out for the
[__] who aren't someone apparently
glad we're not reading theirs I think I
would embarrass myself how about will
Wilkins is will where's will I saw him
earlier where is he well where are you
hey boss how you doing sir a shout out
to will here's what he wrote I've gone
to great lengths to attend this week's
Hollywood babble-on all the way from San
Francisco I'm sure by now I'm worn down
by the inconceivable distance of 326
miles
however it's worth the pain to see you
and Kevin live I'm not just a fan I'm
your audio whipping boy every Sunday yes
will is the sound engineer who posts
Hollywood babble-on on the internet each
and every one he is the conduit it
happens here for everyone in the room
but if you hear it at home man will is
your pusher yes will says my birthday's
this Wednesday the 20th so I would happy
I would be happy if Christian Bale would
tell me that I'm a nice guy but
seriously you and me man were [__]
done professionally
all my best and keep up the great work
little little little Christian Bale's
after looking for oh good for you oh la
dee da dee da oh I put things on
internet now talk like Christian Bale no
no no look you're a nice guy will write
you a nice guy you me a [__] dumb
professionally mate there you go will
thanks for coming out
I saw your hard work sir he has saved my
ass many many times likewise there many
many times Renee and Stuart are you guys
here from Alberta Canada diplomatic
immunity hey speaking of Canada I should
have brought the video clip but but I
just thought finally got around to see
that today you on epicMealTime eating
that that mountain of [__] food the
Burley beavers that was a hell of a
sandwich you were working on was that I
had so much fun doing those dudes are
really really [__] funny but that
sandwich like I was watching it being
made and I was like oh man I'm gonna
have to fake this I took one bite
it was [__] religious it who knew he
put hotdogs next to a [__] bear claw
with some pastrami and some [__]
cheese french fries french fries and
gravy and sugar on top so it's like
eating four courses at once it was
pretty damn good my favorite part of
that whole thing is I'm eating it and I
fall asleep on it yeah because it's very
large like a pillow size and you know
Megan Megan who runs my life at the end
of the show make it was like can I have
that and she took it home and they ate
it for a week like [__] Homer Simpson
with that sandwich it
just cutting off slices it's like
Thanksgiving you're the leftovers rain
started from Alberta Canada
they're here to celebrate somebody's
birthday whose [__] birthday is it
Stewart Stewart's birthday huge fan
listen since day one snout a tradition
for us to listen to your show we're on
road trips when he told me were coming
to LA yeah Renee got him these tickets
as a birthday present here she was
hoping that Charlton Heston could wish
Stewart a happy birthday Renee and
Stewart from Canada or as we call it the
Forbidden Zone dr. Zaius told me not to
go there you won't like it Taylor but I
did and I found a baby that said mama
it's a madhouse get your goddamn
stinking paws off me you dance thinking
Canuck
[Applause]
there you go happy birthday I just watch
plant of the apes again so it's very
fresh it's a lot of details you pulled
the baby and I was like Jesus Christ and
for a second I went away from the show I
was like that was pretty scary
it wasn't it went crazy that was the
moment that I would watch that on the
4:30 movie and I would cover my eyes and
you'd still hear the [__] sound so in
my head the doll was even worse than it
was in the movie growing up man always
had this vision in my head of this hell
doll and [__] and then years later was
adult I actually watched it yeah it's
pretty tame yeah it's just the [__]
doll nothing scary about it really
Francie and and Javier Francie and
Javier hey guys how are they're here
celebrating their engagement because
they're on the second floor oh I got you
would you be singing love is on the
ground if they were in the first one
love is on my neck stop it my face
itches stop they made the long trek from
San Jose to see you sly do you know the
way to San Jose
no sorry stop it you know what when you
get a chance file my [__] in your mouth
captain's just turned on the Belko your
seatbelts I'm not [__] around a
little rough days yeah have you ever
sucked my how much he loves Francie she
is that the best girl ever in fact she
even indulges his nerdiness she
encouraged the use of some pretty nerdy
props during our engagement photos he
wrote here's the he was one of their
engagement photos but supported them
Javier's got Thor's hammer and she's got
Hulk hands on that's adorable
that's pretty cute we're taking the
matrimonial plunge next month I [__] you
not we tried to figure out the Saturday
that made the most sense for our wedding
we ended up picking April 20th as our
wedding date that's right we're getting
married on 4/20 could Kevin using his
kick-ass Bane voice give us the advice
on how to get the most out of a wedding
ceremony that falls on 4/20 this is all
of your expertise in one wheelhouse sir
my name it's hot it's 4/20 everything
I've trained for
you're like Bruce Wayne coming out of
the mountains after you got that [__]
blue flower you're you're ready you're
ready to fight crime at this point
frontier yeah so good of you to join us
how to get the most out of a wedding on
4/20 Ralph's garbage yes mr. bean I
propose you introduce a bit of the
sticky icky put it in a face mask
ooh what are these who has my blue
velvet nice take a segue that's all I
got that ah that's more than enough I
was wondering what would break first
your hymen oh you're back throwing [__]
out there now okay prepare yourselves
it's [__] awesome man what are you
guys getting married for 24 sure how
long you been dating a year thinking do
not get married it's madness the wonder
they're getting married on 4d one year
right on man one of you is very good at
sex
what does it take n you've known each
other for nine but you've only been
engaged involved with one another for
one one of you is very bad closing the
deal he's pointing at Javier what the
patient bad you are to the victor go the
spoils though that's awesome and he
waited for [__] nine years I'll go
have her forever yeah so for eight years
you were just hanging around how they're
going yeah no no no not interested don't
want his penis no don't want it don't
want it now I want his penis just went
on like a light switch did it all right
congratulations you two it's not gonna
end well no it's gonna last forever yeah
that's what I meant to say forever no
I'm good at telling these things that's
a meet-cute story like you read about
man like it took us eight years to [__]
and then we were like [__] it let's get
married
that's the American romance story right
there in a couple years he's gonna be
using the Thor hammer and she's gonna be
using the Hulk gloves trust me
looping them up this is Oh stretch
Brian Liz Justin Paulo Corrine Britney
Rick Heather the Taylors Andy Katie and
pickles I'm sorry they couldn't be with
us tonight that's true which ones
pickles oh it's a dude I guess that
would make sense wouldn't it pickles
he's like look at these pickles mother
guy he's got more yeah I can understand
pickle
but if he's pickles he's a medical
oddity he's got a poor kid [__] you like
that one mmm you speak with forked cop
pickles pickles always reminds me of
Buddy Sorrell remember the old Dick Van
Dyke Show know where he you don't member
the Dick Van Dyke Show one of the
greatest sitcoms ever now that you're
mad at me and say I remember but they
were comedy writers yes and buddy Morey
Amsterdam played a card named buddy and
his wife was named pickles the lady in
the show was pickles no no was his wife
at home you never saw her she's just
referred to like like a beer or
something
yeah with a punch line always but pickle
says what just cuz pickles is a funny
word yes what did the neighbors am boney
I don't know because it wasn't in
candidate didn't take place in Canada if
they had it would have anyway Brian says
sorry for making you read so many names
as well you should be Brian except for
pickles that we have pickles but for my
24th birthday birthday I could think of
nothing better than to get all my
friends together and make the journey
down from Ventura California all right
no need to cheer for Ventura
it's like
we've all been there and a lot of mess
you got that going for you I'm just
saying there's a lot of mess
this dude is straight out of central
casting man he's like come on Ralph
you can do it Ralph huge fans that'd be
awesome to have the gay goes to wish me
a happy birthday
hold on no where the [__] is you can do
it Ralph
[Laughter]
maybe not central casting yeah it's one
of the lesser casting agencies that
doesn't get a lot of work piss-poor
casting I believe a trick
bad timing customer what way who happy
birthday Nancy and Phil Lantis [__]
lively crowd tonight man
nice nice it's like it's like
Chippendales everything's a bachelorette
party everyone's coming with a groups of
12 you're gonna be in a thong and I'm
gonna be working my tits in 20 minutes
the tassels
Phil writes my wife Nancy and I are
attending the show celebrating our 25th
anniversary ah you see you see that's
how it's done
diplomatic longevity how long did you
date before you got married
year and a half so you're just six
months away from happiness Roth can you
please wish us a happy anniversary as
David Bowie well I don't see why not
you seem like a couple of nice kids
Nancy is beautiful funny it's a
wonderful mom to our two kids she makes
every day the best day of my life Phil
wrong someone's gettin upload yeah Phil
and Nancy Lantis tell me you named one
of your kids at have an awesome janaina
atlantis.oh
just getting that
[Applause]
great swimmer gives a great swimmer
where were we oh yeah David Bowie for
your 25th anniversary with us we could
do happy 25th anniversary happy happy
happy Anniversary to you I bet that this
doesn't happen to you happy birthday to
you just watch your penis on me I think
I need a shower
I'm sure
- I I need to be hosed down until I
stand disinfected that was the remix
that was the long duration I was gonna
say I'd already come and put it away man
still [__] it singing I didn't know what
to do that's always the problem Kevin
you always finish before I do I tell you
but in the play most chat is awkward as
well we also get emails sent to us from
literally all around the world the
segment we call the email bag
[Music]
[Applause]
featuring Kevin's reactions Gabe from
San Diego writes a few shows ago Ralph
did the McDonald's fry girl doing the
Christian Bale rant stop it
you know she's not real right you don't
have to go sorry for her I was wondering
if you'll Houser could do the Christian
Bale rant
thanks for the free funny see a
comic-con gave at San Diego I was
thinking about that when I read Gail Z
Gabe's email and I was thinking you'll
Hauser's Christian Bale he's in he's
incapable of being mean right so how can
he do Christian Bale's rant he's got to
do it as a nice guy so here we go oh I
thought you know because he's not alive
anymore
well there's that to do Christian Bale
do it you'll Hauser of a different
taking Christian Bale's
angry rant oh good for you do I come to
your place of work and go lobby da dee
da dee da no no no you're a really nice
guy you're amazing but we're done
professionally
[Applause]
[Music]
well thank you whiskey fairy this
[__] of a weed fairy people are
raising their hands in the audience oh I
got it covered
we're gonna get busted tonight it's the
first night we're actually gonna have
the police show us to prop
just justice just stage we'd Justin from
Boise Idaho writes I hope my wife gets
herpes what the [__] we were on a roll
man
love love hate well here's the
cautionary tale to those of you who just
getting married or have been married for
25 years I'm not some sadist who gets
off on having an itchy crotch let me
elaborate a few days before Valentine's
Day my wife didn't come home after work
I tried to get ahold of her for two days
but I couldn't hold on this is really
sad yeah we haven't said Hulk music
James swimming I think it might be
easier if Casey Kasem tells this story a
few days before Valentine's Day my wife
didn't come home after work I tried but
for two days I couldn't get a hold of
her finally we talked long and short of
it is on Valentine's Day she pulled up
to our house with a u-haul and now she
was leaving me now I don't want her to
die of HIV or anything because I do
still love her and not crabs because I
don't want the solution to be a shave
and a sexy option for the next guy
yes there's another guy so I was hoping
Edwin could wish my wife Jenny a nice
case of a non-life-threatening
venereal disease Justin for Boise Idaho
they grow up cruel and Boise now his
last resort is that Edie winter said his
wife that's that's even worse than
herpes I think oh my goodness Jenny what
a horrible thing you did to this guy
Justin so here's what's gonna happen
you ought to get good drunk and being a
bar two o'clock in the morning and have
sex with a stranger and the next morning
oh my goodness blisters but don't worry
valtrex it's for the living there you go
first I could do Justin Jeremy from
Melbourne Australia writes you offended
a lot of Australians and New Zealanders
last week he's referring referring to my
didgeridoo lightsaber they're our allies
sir that is such an American sentiment
someone overseas pissed off [__] down
well we were talking about didgeridoo
lightsabers last week yeah oh yeah sure
[__] throw me to the wolves man to
your New Zealand hey-oh thanks partner
you may be able to reclaim some
diplomatic immunity with us if you can
have Arnold Schwarzenegger to his best
impression of having an Australian
accent since last week he had an Italian
accent Mel versus Jeremy from Melbourne
right so last week we had Arnold try to
do it Italian accent this week he'd like
mr. Schwarzenegger to do an Australian
not Austrian accent here we go
fosters its Australian for beer mate I
throw another shrimp on the barbie yeah
that's not a knife this is nice ah
[Music]
[Applause]
crikey that manta ray just pierced my
chest
- tsunami you had them and you lost them
what step too far parting gifts ah and
this email comes from burnt lamb he goes
by the name burnt lamb sounds like some
sort of sacrifice to it - Satan burnt
lamb I think he's at Burt lion show host
Burt rights I believe Lindsay Lohan is
officially scraping the bottom of the
barrel if she gave her merchandising
rights to this company apparently
there's a new sex doll available in the
market so Burt Lamb sent us in a photo I
don't know I guess he was in a sex store
it's called the Lindsey blow hand doll
she has three blow holes and the
advertising says she'll steal your heart
and your stash electronic ankle bracelet
not included so we have to get one of
those why so she can co-host now with
him with him I'm not gonna replace him
or anything
Oh three of us together really yeah
what would she bring to the show she'd
be airtight and lastly this email comes
from Allie Nukem in Knoxville Tennessee
you were talking about anchorman 2 last
week and you slipped in a little bit of
the legendary newsman Tom Brokaw I was
thinking I would feel very safe with him
protecting sector 2814 can the guardians
please give him a Green Lantern's ring
and have him say the oath this is a
section we call Rob's Green Lantern's
oath
[Applause]
[Music]
so Ali Newcomb is asking for Tom Brokaw
legendary NBC news anchor for many many
years to do the Green Lantern's oath and
hi Tuesday haka side all right there you
go Ali your Tom Brokaw's to basically
just swallow your tongue yes basically I
was watching you know l's the guy can't
do a lose the other 25 letters as well
by the end so he's a [__] when he
talked about Libya he always had a hard
time I just remember that tonight
bargain alia know that Libya just would
go away every week we say goodbye to
some people show business who left us
with a body of work and we'd like to
thank them now that they've passed on to
the other side a segment we respectfully
call the Tinseltown stiffs
[Music]
they will be missed I will indeed it's
always extra sad when a performer dies
on the set and that's what happened this
week to shark who was doing a Kmart
commercial in Van Nuys when he went
belly-up in a pool a real truck a real
shark what's the story he was shipped
from New York to Los Angeles as if that
wasn't shocking enough for the poor
animal yeah they put him in an
above-ground pool in a neighborhood in
Van Nuys for a commercial for Kmart
here's here's the last picture we have
up shark there he is
yeah that's a pretty big [__] shark
yeah trainers on site tried to give him
oxygen which may have been a mistake
because he [__] breathes water what
we're gonna do I don't know give him
some oxygen what we do for people they
shot him with adrenaline but sadly he
did not get any better if they had to
take him to a specialist in Long Beach
and later that afternoon he passed away
shark was 4 he will he will be missed he
will be missed big bucket of chum yes
shark shark sharks live to be like a
[__] hundred years old yeah so four
is tragically young yeah I made that up
I have no idea how old he was he's a
[__] shark so could you imagine like
you're king of the seas and [__] nothing
[__] with you except maybe a [__]
killer whale or something right somebody
snaps you up you wind up [__] dying
for Kmart yeah there goes our came out
advertising we loved Kmart yeah yeah
except when they kill [__] sharks no
blue light special ajit sir yes also
passed away this week a legendary
drummer for Iron Maiden Clive Burr bass
[Music]
well yes - yes decline I'm not - not to
death alright you're not hearing death
say boy they hated that [__]
finally the [__] guy he died he was
the Hitler of Iron Maiden
he left us after three [__] I'll upon
dude [__] [__] anyway dude
the Beast the Beast dude dude died he
joined made in 1997 played on their
first three studio albums Iron Maiden
the first in 1980 killers and 81 and
then the number of the beast which was
kind of their breakthrough album great
drummer by the way enormous drummer
sadly he was stricken with MS later in
life and he couldn't he couldn't oldest
Styx any longer couldn't perform any
longer which was just a nightmare for
him as you can imagine Iron Maiden did
the right thing to help defray all of
his medical costs by having a series of
concert concerts they used to called
clive aid which was oh that's cute and
they started a trust fund and performing
various charity concerts and having
various events to try to raise money to
offset his medical expenses so they took
care of their own which is nice for
those of you who aren't familiar with
Iron Maiden's work or even more
especially for those of you are here is
the the breakthrough song run to the
hills' that you can hear clive drumming
on just a little taste of Iron Maiden
[Music]
that's drumming his ass off for that
that's a huge bucket of wind man he's
gonna be missed
you know you do yourself a favor now you
watch the Iron Maiden videos from the
day and you're saying oh it's [__]
spinal tap it's amazing that they look
pick up is that the vibe is that song
run to the hills is about the American
Indians being abused by white people and
everything and it's just it just it
smacks a little bit of Stonehenge there
one of those kind of songs really it's
very entertaining and lastly this week
malachi throne passed away you may not
know his name but he was a great
character actor from the 60s he was on a
TV series with Robert Wagner called it
takes a thief which I remember as a kid
I don't know if they rerun it anymore
but that was a great show Robert Wagner
played a jewel thief like a cool Cary
Grant yeah exactly and malachi throne
played his boss he made him steal for
the government he took them out of
prison in order to make him go off and
steal for the US Secret Service he was
also on Star Trek the original series
played Commodore Jose Mendez you may
remember from menagerie parts 1 & 2 he
was great on it you know originally he
was offered the role of dr. McCoy on
Star Trek bones owns but he passed said
I'll do Spock but I won't do bones which
is how I always felt really about all of
them because he said he'd want to be the
third banana he wanted to be the second
banana or nothing so he passed on that
but they brought him back I'll do Spock
I'll do bones with a banana no you're
missing the point but the reason I loved
him so much was he made a guest
appearance on the TV series Batman where
he played a villain know his false face
he played false face on that show look
in one episode it was a two-parter yeah
he played it in two episodes but he
played the false face the villain who
was the master of disguise right but
Batman or Robin would always see through
his disguise for some reason because you
know they're Batman and Robin so I
brought in a little taste of the episode
true or false face where he first
appears here's Adam West and Burt Ward
as Batman and Robin confronting Malachi
throne as falseface
[Music]
now we've come to prevent it withdraws
white phosphorus what false face
notorious criminal master of disguise
and we put a lot of money in the truck
before it's too late old buddy right
that's false face himself in disguised
person yeah sure it's obvious only a
criminal would disguise himself as a
licensed bonded guard yet callously park
in front of a fire hydrant that's how I
got him only a criminal would park in
front of a fire hydrant he is the Dark
Knight detective that's right a little
piece of trivia for you you'll
appreciate malachi throne also narrated
the original trailer for Star Wars in
1977 while we're talking about Batman
and Adam West it's my honor to award him
with this week's Hollywood helper
[Music]
this week's Hollywood helper is Batman
Adam West remembers Zach the kid who was
who's battling cancer and Christian
Bale's sent him a whole shitload of
Batman stopped and then called him up at
the hospital well not to be outdone Adam
West this week sent Zach a bigger box of
Batman stuff and better better stuff and
it probably didn't have that stupid
voice to it either that's right oh are
you feeling better I hope can't release
your body just want to hear that when
he's in the hospital that voice is
scaring children what you want to hear
is the is the warm baritone of Adam West
on the other end of the hall so Adam
called Zach in the hospital this week
and was talking him about that man and
Zach was thrilled to be talking to
another Batman he's a huge Batman fan he
had one question in particular for Adam
West regarding the the movie that Adam
did the 1966 Batman movie here's Zach
talking to Adam West with his question
[Laughter]
how did that shark feel on your leg that
goes I still have the scar
oh yeah so it's nice of Adam to call in
a good guy
every week we take a look at some famous
movie stars who turn in perhaps less
than great performances but sometimes
they go so far around being bad they
come back to exquisite it's called
exquisite acting welcome to the world of
exquisite acting with Ralph Garman this
week's exquisite acting comes from Jared
Parrish in San Jose California
do you guys know Josh he said last week
you guys featured Kevin Sorbo
TVs Hercules with the famous line of him
being disappointed do we have a we have
a little taste of that from last week
James James we will taste that from last
week I'm just so bored no it's just it's
just a piece of audio it's just a little
piece of audio just some there we go
Jared rights I thought another great
exquisite acting to follow the theme
would be the great Gary Oldman from one
of my favorite movies The Fifth Element
from 1997 one good disappointed deserves
another rights Jared so here is Gary
Oldman chewing the scenery a little bit
from the Fifth Element
[Music]
[Laughter]
all psorbos got to beat the only ass so
far she's in these in front also every
week we take a look at mistakes that
happen in the movies that we always say
the hundreds of pairs of eyes look at
every TV show every movie before they
reach the audience and yet still stuff
slips through it's the second week all
[__] that should not be this week [__]
this should not be it's the return of
Logan's run we had that once before
remember the guy's ass was on fire
during that one flight that was pretty
spectacular Paul writes in and says that
the end of Logan's Run is the crowd
gathers around the old man remember the
movie to remember that they all die but
the age of 30 they don't any longer but
they find one guy Peter Ustinov who's
lived outside of their community and
he's an old craggly man and all the
young people go up and start touching
him and they surround him at the end of
the film because they can't believe
someone could live past the age of 30 as
they all gather around how do you make
me want to watch it you're cool I love
your dramatic retell oh thank you as
they all gather around you see the old
man waving to Logan you see a lone hand
from an extra in the crowd slowly creep
up says Paul the moral of story is don't
hire geeks as extras here's the video
and if you miss it I have got a picture
of it afterwards here's the very end of
Logan's Run
[Music]
can we throw up the still of that that
[__] extra [__] Star Trek fans
gonna [__] it up for everybody that dude
won the wrong there was no internet man
oh he's a genius he was just gonna find
it someday this is gonna be on the
internet long and prosper [__]
guys show's been canceled for seven
years but I'm still [__] rocking this
photo bombing me you don't do that to
another sci-fi franchise you don't throw
the Vulcan sign up there it's
inappropriate Star Trek movie you don't
see a guy with like a Yoda hand puppet
seeking it up over the you know the pod
bay there's no like Yoda gang sign that
you could throw up and unless you're
doing like a Yoda shadow puppet or
something like that like this is easy
like live long and prosper you could
sneak that in anywhere yeah even in bed
live long and prosper I think it's
called the Shocker or the spotter I
guess that would be you word it thank
you so much Russell may be disappointed
I waited a week for but that's what was
right there god bless you this is I know
Kevin doesn't like this segment but it
may be my personal favorite each and
every week we take Kevin and you the
Hollywood babble-on listeners stick him
in a place that's wildly inappropriate I
love to see where keV is in
we have the theme we have the cabin at
the Kevin theme song do we have the
Kevin theme song we don't have it all
right we'll just go without it that's
what is that all about that that's the
the third the third element of the cabin
segment we'll get to that in a minute
wait to get to that let's go to a couple
pictures first the Iron Man 3 trailer it
came out last week it'll be the
extension out awesome very exciting to
see some prolonged images of the
Mandarin I think we were all surprised
to find out who was playing the Mandarin
when we first saw the trailer weren't we
yeah not as intimidating not as
intimidating as I thought he'd be they
called me a teacher that's [__] too
fat to fight right there man well you
got all the rings you don't need those
you know ten rings and rings yeah Victor
I'm following that that was genius
yeah that was pretty strong Kevin also
had a bad week in the UK and if you saw
that or not he he had a he was late for
a show he had a bad birthday party and
then he tried to pick a fight with a
paparazzo to know if you saw it or not
that was a little embarrassing for Kevin
Kevin storming out of the SUV trying to
approach him
have you seen you've seen the real
picture right of course yes yes it looks
like that dude is picking them up oh
yeah that's either that's a very big
dude or Justin is a dwarf
and lastly this segment usually is just
the photographs but Matt from Harrisburg
Pennsylvania sent in a little audio
Kevin he said credit to black Jesus HD
for the music stems and to whatever
strain was smoking that night but Kevin
a couple episodes ago awhile back went
off on this book of mormon rant he's
seen it go see it it's on the road now
spreading out across the united states
it's in the UK as well if you haven't
seen it see it is the best piece of art
ever produced by human beings ever could
you're not overselling that in a no I'm
telling you I've never met anybody who's
been like I heard you say it and I saw
it you're out of your mind everybody's
like it's better than you even said I'm
saying like Sistine Chapel and stuff I
mean there's other things that have been
done Sistine Chapel you're paying a
[__] ceiling deal man
these [__] came up with don't
[__] to baby yeah that's Kevin's
favorite song from that musical so Matt
from Harrisburg said sometimes he gets
an itch do a mash-up and he just can't
rest until it's finished so here is a
mashup of Kevin singing from The Book of
Mormon and Carly Rae Jepsen singing her
hit here's a little taste
[Music]
very good
that's your audio Kevin for the night my
I got a 13 year old kid right and she's
on to like dark music and [__] like that
Jax metal why not I played that in the
car once and she just looked at me so
appalled she reached over and she shut
her off and she was like no dad no
bubbly and fun she's like no dad no so I
can't listen to it around my kid the
worm in my office is [__] nobody's
around like I'm not nuts right it's a
fun cooking it's like Jessie's Girl I
always get those people give me [__]
because I'm a huge Rick Springfield fan
because those three minutes [__]
well-crafted pop songs with some but
it's really done right you just can't
beat it gets in your skin it's like
[__] heroin it's musical heroin you
know it's bad for you but you're like
[__] jamming it into your veins I just
snorted I don't shoot it oh you know
what you're missing man yeah one day
let's take a look at the week's big
stories in the entertainment world with
the HBO headlines
[Music]
biggest story entertainment this week
had to be the amazing phenomenon that
was the Veronica Mars Kickstarter
campaign this caught everybody by
surprise Rob Thomas creator of Veronica
Mars very popular TV show I wasn't very
popular it was it was a cult cult it I
was on it I know I remember that yeah it
was on the I guess the WB right at first
and then it went to the CW went up so
they decided that for a long time the
fans have been asking for a movie they
want to get the cash for unite it and do
a movie and nobody would back in nobody
really warrants doing so Rob Thomas and
its star Kristen Bell get together and
they say let's throw it up on
Kickstarter and if we will take 30 days
and we can raise just the bare minimum
of two million dollars the production
cost then we'll make the the movie so
they throw it up at 7:30 in the morning
this week and in four hours and 24
minutes they had reached 1 million
dollars in biology which everyone said
was unheard of it broke in a record no
nothing on Kickstarter to be made that
much money before I thought Amanda
Palmer did she made a million bucks in
four hours and no not I think yes yeah
it was for you know four and a half
hours it was ridiculous to make that
kind of money it was the absolute wise
move you have an audience that's
motivated online I can't tell you how
many people have [__] hashtag me over
the years like Veronica Mars movie
making it happen like keep tweeting it
and stuff
so the the audience is there the the fan
base completely motivated once this
Springs out and they kept this very
quiet Dan Etheridge who's a friend of
ours and he has done podcasts on smut KO
he did dan him the Dan Marty show nooner
with Deanna Marty he's a producer and
always has been on Veronica Mars
so Dan was kind of letting me know on
what was how long they were planning it
he said this goes back almost a year
nine months or something like that and
they were terrified that would leak out
they want to keep it quiet because first
one who did this first one that one fall
word and said I'm gonna [__] and
finance the movie off the fan base
was gonna break some kind of record like
that particularly if you could motivate
your fanbase so they said they kept it
so [__] quiet never leaked out once
and then boom just Wednesday had
happened and they didn't expect they
didn't expect this nearly what happened
they thought they'd get there over the
course third days they're pretty
confident they'd get there right when it
happened the day had happened it was
amazing four and half hours reached 1
million by 11 hours later they had
reached their goal of 2 million dollars
and they get himself 30 days to do it
so as of before we left to come here to
do the show I looked at the numbers it's
a three and a half million dollars so
far that's what and then a million and a
half I guess we're blowing hookers I
guess we robbed them congratulations
good good for you Rob Rob said about the
event he said we better make a good
movie it's true and you think the fans
have put up the money you know they got
some say I paid for this piece of [__]
all they have to do is make a flick as
good as the strongest episode and I
think and show her tits no yes if I put
in like a hundred bucks to the Marana
Kumar's movie I better see Veronica's
mounds I don't think you understand the
spirit of that show I understand it's
appear to my penis that's what I
understand she's out of high school now
fair game top off let's go come on
Veronica put him on the glass that's
what we're all saying oh man she's smart
you look at her brain [__] yeah
I'll look at her brain from the inside
[Applause]
looks good from the inside where do you
think the brain is up that way where I
am due north let's take a look at the
celebrity sick bay a lot of people not
feeling well this week Lil Wayne rapper
Lil Wayne was hospitalized yesterday oh
come on don't you love the sizzurp can I
get a couple scissors up here for me and
Kevin please
what is scissor the scissor Kevin is the
preferred drink of some particular
rappers it's codeine cough syrup mixed
with Mountain Dew we've talked about
this it's Rowan a couple Jolly Ranchers
you got yourself a cocktail right there
like that [__] up it's a flaming Moe
that's right a little Wayne is addicted
to it so say some sources and he went
into the hospital for seizures on
Tuesday to cedars-sinai they let him out
when he stopped seizing and then they
bless you they found him unconscious in
his room days later and rushed him back
to the hospital and sources say it's
because he keeps downing the copious
amounts of sizzurp
which by the way Justin Bieber
apparently likes as well so fingers
crossed
can we send just in case a complimentary
keg of sizzurp I just want to share our
Canadian friends you are safe here just
don't make music he doesn't like don't
make shitty music period it as your
beloved as your lieu grants TVs Lou
Grant was sick this week he's doing a
one-man show around the country about
the president FDR and he was on can't
stop this dude he's always working 83
years old still on stage doing a one-man
show and the they were watching from the
wings and apparently he started to sweat
profusely and forget his lines and he
started to stumble they could tell he
wasn't well so they rushed him to the
hospital but apparently he didn't they
they initially they were afraid if it
was a stroke or something but apparently
he was just exhausted and wasn't eating
right and he got a couple days rest and
he's great sources say however he still
is on the scissor so Mary
get me some scissor Ted where's my
scissor was he also an up was he was the
voice of the old man up what a great
performance that breaks a woman's but
the opening [__] five minutes of up
dude holy Sh crying like a business sad
as the last 10 minutes of [__]
Schindler's List schindler's list or
Schindler's toy box which is Toy Story 3
that's right but it's [__] sad man
like you see the couple together and
then all of a sudden they slowly age and
she falls and yeah tearjerker man but a
lovely flick and he doesn't kill her
[__] job in that flip you know what
got his wife in that movie sizzurp yeah
I got her Lady Bird the dog at one port
was like scissor well Lady Gaga's
recovering from her hip surgery what
really what happened here she got an
infection in her hip in her joint and
they had to operate to fix it she had to
cancel a bunch of tour dates and I
remember hearing that but this is why
yeah so she's recovering now but in true
Lady Gaga fashion she is currently
working her way around the neighborhood
in the world's most expensive wheelchair
is it made of meat Ralph it isn't that
would be awesome if she was actually in
a chair full of meat I'd push her around
but the chair would get smaller and
smaller this wheelchair is coated in 24
karat gold okay is there another show
going on here just seemed like there was
a murmur going through the kromega
Mangler you wouldn't like him when he's
angry
is there breaking news did we miss
something was there an earthquake or are
you just an [__] she's in the world's
most expensive wheelchair now that you
got the moustache you're starting to
come off like a 70s cop that was real
Serpico and Cher you're like such a
[__] mouth [__]
pick your feet mackynzie
24 karat gold wheelchair yes
that's what she's traveling around in
for I don't know six months how long she
needs 24 karat gold wheelchair purse
because it's that [__] Lady Gaga
person who's like look at me so of
course she's gonna be in that wheelchair
but a regular wheelchair would work just
as well I know but she's got to have a
little bling to it this is why the
terrorists hate us because there's women
who wear meat and they're starving and
then they you push around a gold
wheelchair and they're they'd have no
legs some of them I don't know I'm just
saying they're angry leave her alone man
she's just born this way here's a
picture of the 24 karat gold wheelchair
by the way yeah that's a nice ride
that's not as nice as my car I mean my
car's not as nice as that I wish I had
that I put a rocket on the back Sarah
Jessica Parker also sick she's not doing
well
uh-oh whooping mouth disease
[Music]
she apparently all those years in heels
on Sex in the City and all the stuff
that she's always been doing running
around in heels and [__] out of here her
feet are deformed now she is true she
can no longer wear high heels because
the doctor the foot doctor and my
kidding said you have your foot does
things that shouldn't be able to do that
bone there you've created that bone it
doesn't belong in a human foot she like
my well you know how they used to bind
women's feet and [__] that's what she
kind of [__] was happening her feet have
become hideous we have a picture of one
of her feet can we take a look yeah look
at that oh my god is disgusting it's the
ugliest foot I've ever seen looks like
do they really have a picture of her
foot no they don't it's not a
good-looking foot I could have put a
hoof up there but I'm trying to mix
things up
[__] tape Kim Kardashian is in the news
this week
[Music]
[Applause]
the Kim has said publicly I'll try
anything that makes me look and feel
youthful she said so this week she went
to a spa and got a vampire facial no
it's it's not going down on your lady
when she's on her period fellas its I
[Music]
[Applause]
wanted to correct them before they went
in the wrong direction I may have just
found my line yes also known as the
rusty taco thank you thank you good
night everybody the vampire facial
here's what they do they take blood out
of your arm and then they spin it to
remove all the platelets so it's plasma
and then they you take a needle and they
inject your own blood back into your
face now this is supposed to make your
skin youthful and rejuvenate basically
here's a picture of Kim after she had
the procedure Oh
who took that picture a close personal
friend I'm guessing of all the things
Kim Kardashian's had on her face I think
this is the worst what else has been on
her face right Oh Reggie Bush
Kris Humphries what how does the picture
like this get out and she shook it and
she posted it she posted the picture
like look at me feel bad yes why would
you do that because it's gonna be on one
of her TV shows and AG upcoming episode
I got you
she also said that was very painful oh
my god I'll never get a facelift if it
feels like that she said about having
the needles put in her face
well childbirth should be a joy for you
then can look forward to it while we're
talking about the Kardashians Kris
Jenner the pimp of the Kardashian
fountain sorry the manager of the
Kardashian family
momager a momager she has put together
the power couple for the next generation
of Kardashian's her daughter Kylie 15
year old daughter Kylie Jenner
she has been set up via Kris Jenner with
Jaden Smith Will Smith's son who's also
15 years old the Karate Kid
the Karate Kid Chris believes that if
she can put those two together they'll
have a whole brand new merchandising
opportunity if they've become a power
couple
it's like Kanye and Kim Jayden and Kylie
why don't you sell your children into
white slavery just be done with it just
sell them to some sort of chic somewhere
and make a big killing and then go to
Acapulco and relax what kind of
percentage do you think you'd pull as
the momager I mean most managers take 15
but what is a momager who really kind of
created this [__] off of the back of her
daughter's [__] tape like she must pull
at least [__] 50% I'm guessing it's
the same 15 but they also remember they
they tithe every 10% of everything to
the church which is the Church of Kris
Jenner that's a church that you invented
they honored that she actually has her
own church the the Church of the
relentless [__] I think it's called our
lady our Lady of the no shame Holly
Madison speaking of reality stars she
was one of Hugh Hefner's girlfriends she
was on that reality show The Girls Next
Door remember did you talk about the
snack cake now that's the Dolly Madison
that's a different fan
ha we ready go hole like the peanuts
used to do commercials for those route
singers yeah Holly Madison had her first
child that she knows of this week and
she's not bright she could have had a
couple and just fell out you don't know
it's her first child and it's a daughter
and she's named her rainbow Aurora now
that may be you may think that's a
shitty name but she is defending it this
week very aggressively saying there are
a lot of smug haters out there who bag
on my choice of name but I don't care
what they think I want my daughter to be
proud of who she is and to learn to
speak up and stand up for herself at an
early age so you give her a cruel name
exactly that teaches our character I
like it the rainbow roars I think kind
of cute second choice was Hitler Hitler
Madison now that would build did not -
but Holly's right I mean if your kid's
gonna end up on the pole anyway just cut
to the chase and give her a stripper
name said that by time she's 18 she's
good to go she doesn't have to spend all
that time thinking up one ladies and
gentleman welcome rainbow to the stage
rainbow stage one put your dollar bills
out there guys she doesn't work for
applause it's rainbow coming up to stage
number one
rainbows available the VIP room fellas
buying champagne for rainbow have you
done that I wish that's my dream [__]
job ready to go you've been practicing
yeah well I heard it in my ears I love
my whole life just leaning over the
[__] railing just hey you know I
think we need to get a theme song for
Justin Bieber for this show because he's
in the news every week we're gonna have
to work on that this week of course was
a big week in Justin Bieber news he he
tried to beat up a photographer in the
UK he had a show canceled for the first
time ever in Portugal they for lack of
ticket sales they had to cancel one of
his dates and this
it's starting to turn man it's starting
it's starting to turn those who didn't
see the scuffle he got in on the last
Friday with the photographer who's
trying to beat him up here's a picture
of him is his bouncer trying to put him
back and into the the SUV apparently
Justin had missed his nap so they had to
make sure he got into his car seat
safely he looks like a puppet or a
pillow baby of some sort
meanwhile I never thought these two
would cross paths but the Lindsay Lohan
is in the news you were doing math there
for a minute you look like the Pope with
it um what am I don't send me your money
that's what we'd say when we were altar
boys they come spiritu - Oh we'd said
they're gonna send me your money
Justin Bieber post an insanely long rant
on Instagram this week defending himself
against all the people who have been
coming down on him in the press he says
that the reason they're slamming him is
because I'm 19 and it must be scary to
some people to think that this is just
the beginning
you're just jealous man cuz he's 19 and
this is just the beginning yo
you don't know you don't know j-jake P
Oh Bieber every saga has an ending
I'm sure corey feldman fell when he was
19 they're all they're all just jealous
cuz i'm in license to drive and i'm 19
yo i'm gonna be [__] huge
now i'm selling my teeth on ebay i don't
know if the is reanalysis guys gotta
make a buck right so at the end of this
long read the reason Lindsay's name has
come up because it and those comparing
me to Lindsay Lohan look at her 2012 tax
statements boom this whole big thing is
like I make more money I'm rich that
means I'm better cuz he's a prick yes I
think at this point we understand your
feelings about Justin Bieber ma'am
meanwhile the the female Bieber if you
will K tops whittler was also in the
news this week she needs a theme songs
yeah she says she shows up every week as
well there was a woman who going into a
dumpster behind an elementary school
this week and they found [__] loads of
Taylor Swift fan letters in there they
were all been written to Taylor Swift
and someone had just dumped a shitload
of fan mail in the dumpster and this
woman contacted the local news in
Nashville and said Taylor Swift [__]
throws up letters people are trying to
contact her she loves your fan so much
they're throwing out her fan letters
well because she's a prick yeah
congratulations you have a catch phrase
now next week we'll be selling he's a
prick t-shirt she's a prick teacher
it's not just he's and she's it's
because he's a prick
so naturally her representative said oh
there must've been some mistake we would
never do that
Taylor loves her fans in fact we're
gonna collect all those letters and
we're gonna make sure that they are
dealt with appropriately they said in a
statement and then they burn them burn
burn burning in Hellfire that's what
they burned in even jeopardy now hates
Tait ups with her and if you saw this or
not thanks to listener Matt rau bottom
he sent in this still store from his TV
show he was watching jeopardy and this
question came up 2009 'the best female
country vocal went to her for white
horse where she shocker goes off on an
ex-boyfriend
I'll take town list guns for 500 Alex
and the answer is and well it's at the
Daily Double
speaking of talentless [__] Chelsea
Handler was in the news this week look I
I'm even I'm bored of my hatred for
Chelsea Handler but every once in a
while she does something so [__]
obnoxious that even I can't ignore it
any longer she was in Aspen Colorado at
a restaurant where she and her crew were
getting shit-faced in the middle of the
day and there was a group of businessmen
the next table that's 60 years old and
witnesses tell the New York Post that
she started to throw bread at the old
man pelting them with biscuits and
various forms of bread goods okay that's
[__] obnoxious spring break she's not
18 she's 57 years old for [__] sake
she should know better what have the old
guys were harassing them or saying some
[__]
yeah I'm sure those old men really
starting [__] or with it you know oh
we're going to foreclose on your
mortgage you kids you whippersnappers
with having [__] lunch and it's a
wonderful life nine of them no but she's
bad that's my point
I like her I think she's got moxie I
hate spunk that's what she's got she's
got spunk all over here the guy who got
the Netflix tattoo loves Netflix so much
he got tattooed no yeah he he loves his
[__] downloads this guy here's the
poached picture he put online this this
month every to make about Netflix the
tattoo he contacted the organization and
said I want to do a commercial for you
look at me I've got a Netflix tattoo and
he wanted to make some money on
apparently and they said we'll give you
a year free download that's it once what
he got maybe should have negotiated this
deal before he got the [__] tattoo
shot a little footage or something like
that this would be like me as a child
getting ColecoVision tattooed on
like [__] just goes away and every once
in a while we take a look at the
upcoming movies and we can just tell
that one of them is going to [__]
suck this week it was announced I'm
always delighted to not be on the list
yeah you know your movie your movie
hasn't promised to suck but this one
does sony has announced they are
adapting the 1970s sitcom good times and
turning it into a major motion picture
[Music]
where is the demand for good times I'll
tell you what Sony here do this go to
Kickstarter and open up the good times
movie finance page and see if people
donate two million dollars to see
[__] dynomite see if anybody wants to
see that on the big screen
I love the boobs song though I got real
excited when you're like good times
movie I was just like who the good times
you you can listen to the theme song
without that being a 90-minute movie
behind it I agree there's no real reason
I could see to make this flick unless
there's somebody like that wants to do
it in a big bad way somebody very very
famous Scott Rudin is the director he's
the one who bought the project he's the
producer he's producing it yeah and that
sound you hear is Tyler Perry swinging
from from a shower curtain rod right now
how did I not think of that
he said that's like a horrible black
centric movie why didn't I come up with
that good times with Madea
hallelujah dynomite
JJ you gotta call him up give him a pep
talk and just be like keeping your head
above water man making a wave if you can
[Music]
really do love that show man
when I was a kid that was my
I wore black yes my parents would be the
likewise he identify with us so much
John Amos would come into your house we
know all that I used to tell my father I
was like that you should really threaten
to hit me in order to raise me properly
that's what they do on good times yeah
yeah I'm glad we're taking that 70s
black culture and bringing it to the
current movie screen where black fathers
conveniently threatened to beat and whip
their kids best episode of that show and
if they did this as the movie I would
totally [__] go there was one episode
would have this neighbor lady who was
older yeah and there was a rumor going
out throughout the building that she was
eating dog food no money she was on
welfare child no they invited don't
[__] laugh it was kind of funny so uh
so they invite her over to eat and she
brings like a meatloaf and the whole
episode is everybody be like finding a
way to pass on the meatloaf because they
think she made it with [__] dogs
today but then at the end of the episode
she figures it out and she tells him
she's like even though I have to eat dog
food you don't think I'd do that to my
friends right and she like left it was
really hard that was a great [__]
show maybe but I can't see them doing it
as a feature you know what I'm saying it
had a weekly feel to it in terms of like
dealing with the issues and whatnot I
don't know how many issues you could put
into a 90-minute movie that'll feel
fresh and relevant at the end of that
story though it turns out the meatloaf
was made of actual dog it wasn't dog
food she was a Korean neighbor and so
dae-su don't remember thank you thank
you for the racist sound effects I can't
get into enough trouble on my own good
lord man you want to come down here with
one of those [__] hats and pull it
your eyes a little bit James anything
else you want to get to our let's that's
hurry up we still hey can i real quick
what is the category we were just on
movies that will slow bees that will
suck yeah I'll give a quick shout-out to
myself because I just tweeted before I
came here today this evening to do the
show I will read you the tweet as soon
as it loads up it was loading in the
meantime how are you Ralph here we go
on page on page 59 of clerks 3 Wow
[Applause]
I said it might be the midway point in
love with it but still able to edit -
gonna revise and trim til it's only page
45 I've been writing since last week and
it's [__] I'm having a blast man it's
like hanging out with old friends and
whatnot and then getting to move the
story forward and the stuff that I'm
kind of layering in that people who like
the movies we've done before
particularly the clerks films are gonna
love a little Easter Egg type [__] cuz
this is the one that closes everything
up once I'm done making this movie I'm
not gonna direct feature films anymore
and say so I'm gonna go out with no one
do that I'm gonna do other [__] don't
worry about it trust me I'm sadder than
you are he's the only directly they will
hire me but that's that is why I brought
it up because you're already there man
what
I have lines and everything yes you plan
and true to form you play in terms of on
this show of course you're the man of 90
voices in the in the flick you're gonna
play multiple parts as well Wow
very exciting I'll let you know as I
keep going with have all the key players
signed off and agreed to this project
nope if I know that was sort of a hurdle
before this some yeah yeah and some big
players weren't injuries to talk about
the Veronica Mars Kickstarter and it was
a rather bittersweet I'm so happy for
them I loved Anitha which I'm glad they
made the money they did because I love
Veronica Mars look forward to seeing it
but in November we almost did that we
ran three Kickstarter and you know that
would have been [__] cool we could
have been first through the door and
[__] we're gonna let the audience
finance it but then Jeff Anderson was
like hold the roll man I didn't sign off
on this yeah there's still some
accounting to be done for clerks too
with the Weinstein Company he wants to
make sure that got done he's like look
let them finish clerks too before we
even have a conversation about clerks
three so I had to pull the brake and and
kind of but you're going on now he's
sort of Sighs fuse this I was like never
mind just sitting there and telling them
it's gonna be great it's gonna be great
it's like it all begins with a script so
I told myself just [__] sit down
reason he likes it it might perhaps let
him off so I'm like halfway through now
like I said I'll probably trim it back
and whatnot but it's it's pretty strong
if its content he's not worried about
content with the content well I think
hook I'm alone it's pretty cool or I
could start working now on my Anderson
impression he's gonna do it he's gonna
be awesome Kevin and I are big geek so
every week we also like to take a look
at the geek news of the week
[Applause]
[Music]
this week's geek news mark ruffalo has
announced they will be no standalone
Hulk movie why why that's dumb that's
[__] dumb they're making a good times
movie but they're not Meghan Hall now
see this is this is now you're on my
side let it go you sir have said it what
madness why he said lots of folks have
been asking about the next Hulk movie
but the next time you'll see my Hulk
will be Avengers 2 he's up for it he
wants to put the powers that be won't
give it a green light I guess they're a
little a little shy because they've had
a series of Hulk failures [__] after
the Avengers you could give a two-hour
Hulk movie where all he does is sit
there and take a [__] and people will
[__] tune they'll tune and they'll
show up man that Hulk an Avenger is such
a commercial for the next Hulk movie it
doesn't matter what the plot line will
be people will [__] go because they
did them right for the first time you're
like holy [__] don't turn on sad music
this is sad Hulk oh [__] he said I'm not
giving up on another stand alone Hulk
but it's not in the works right now with
Marvel one never knows what the future
will bring though so he's trying to take
a positive take but it sounds like it's
not even on the drawing boards so change
it changes you got Iron Man 3 coming up
then Captain America First Avenger not
First Avenger Winter Soldier and then
Thor 2 also so they got a lot in the
pipeline but Hulk is not among them
apparently you know it is right around
the corner we're talking about comic
book movies kick-ass 2 if you saw the
trailer hit this week I was a little
concerned did you read the books did you
read the kick-ass the sequel a new
kick-ass but in another sequel it would
I read it and it was [__] brilliant I
said I just hope that Vaughan closely
he's great did Vaughan do it yeah and I
said I hope they'd hear us closely to
the the second set of books as they did
to the first and from what I've seen in
the trailer they absolutely do
everybody's back chloe moretz of course
aaron taylor-johnson as kick-ass hit
girl they're all back now what scared me
was the casting of Jim Carrey as Colonel
stars and stripes it's like the the Nic
Cage stunt casting of the first one but
I think it pulls off here's just a
little
to introduce Jim Carrey's character to
Colonel stars and stripes here's a
little taste of the new trailer for
kick-ass 2
[Music]
there's a dog on your balls
that little girl is so amazing she's
yeah she was she keeps getting better
she's an amazing actress and she's got
so much charisma yeah yeah she 18 yet 16
listen this guy's the [__] countdown
pounder so as she ages sixteen sixteen I
know they're sixteen and twenty twenty
seven days until she's 18
I was like who's worse than you and then
he was like me that guy he's got the
Jergens on there on the desk a box of
tissues the countdown calendar just
staring at it there woman named Heather
large in the news this week in the geek
news easy her name she's a regular
person weird look like though 39 year
old woman does she is she large I don't
know if she's large or not cuz that
would be [__] ironic it wouldn't be
but I'm thinking if her name's had the
large she probably takes extra care to
try to be as thin as possible but the
thing is she's pregnant that's the story
in the news that she's pregnant and she
got her ultrasound back just before she
gave birth to the baby and it ended up
on the internet because it turns out
that she is giving birth to Emperor
Palpatine from Star Wars don't take my
word for it I brought it in the
ultrasound for you to take a look at
this is an actual ultrasound this has
not been doctored this is an actual
ultrasound here's the guy here's her
uterus that's what's going on inside her
now the baby has been born since that
photo and by all accounts it's a
beautiful perfectly normal baby now
next thing you know mad strike me down
with y'all hate chanting Heather's
husband saw the ultrasound and said
[Applause]
Lucas said I can fix that ultrasound
later to put some CGI in there
everything Heather is both amused and
slightly disturbed that images of her
uterus are making the rounds on the
internet she said last week I can
imagine so folks each and every week we
like to say goodbye with some facts
about a certain gentleman's penis he is
a he's a very talented Irish actor and
legend has it he has an enormous [__] so
each and every week we ask the musical
question just how big is Liam Neeson's
[__] you go to Neeson [__] calm to post
your own facts about Liam's [__] we we
appreciate it these are all submitted by
you the listener and we appreciate it
this worse the first one comes from Dave
from Santa Clarita California Liam
Neeson's [__] is so big it takes a team
of Teamsters to deliver his condoms Dave
sent in photographic evidence of that
fact here are some Teamsters delivering
one of his condom and its ribbed for her
pleasure which i think isn't it's nice
we appreciate that Dave Liam Neeson's
[__] is so big it now consistently beats
NBC in the ratings
well what network doesn't really it's
not such a big deal a mondo [__] hey
Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
it is outsource its helpdesk to India
hello Liam Neeson's cut how can I help
you my name is Ken yes wait mrs. [__] is
so big marshal will and Holly fell into
his urethra and now they're fighting the
sleestaks that was a [__] show I love
that deadlock show will and Holly
routine expedition on the rapids aboard
their tiny raft and down a valley deep
below to the line
and of the
[Music]
[Applause]
we're Neeson's [__] is so big when
Hercules tried to lifted it he was
disappointed Liam Neeson's [__] is so
big white smoke billing a lot of
billowing out of it means we have a new
pope and he needs to get to a urologist
I would think no idea what this next one
means but I let me laugh so hard I had
to include it Liam Neeson's [__] is so
big it'll turn your chocolate starfish
into a caramel octopus I don't know I
don't know I just imagine just like
pieces of calamari everywhere it's just
like a milky caramel color I did Carmel
octopus gives me the impression there's
a beak in there somewhere or tentacles
even worse I'll take that Liam Neeson's
[__] is so big
Joe Rogan firmly believes that only
alien technology could have constructed
it he's one of those
and lastly Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
an 89 year old Japanese soldier recently
crawled out of it and had to be told
World War two was over ladies and
gentlemen a Hollywood if they had a good
time this evening thank you so much for
a wonderful evening for us you guys have
been absolutely fantastic thanks for
being here for us selling the joint out
come back again please man but for now
that is Hollywood babble-on for this
week I'm Kevin Smith catalog
at the water
[Music]
[Applause]